so i've done some stuff since we last
spoke where we last left off i had just
finished building the nas and had added
a 10 gigabit switch the next addition to
the rack is a 48 port patch panel the
patch panel is used to cleanly redirect
the ethernet cabling back to the
machines in the actual rack essentially
it's just there to keep things clean in
the front and just for like organization
there's lots of ways that you can manage
ethernet cables i just happen to like
the way this looks best next i added my
16 port gigabit switch which i'll be
using for anything that doesn't need to
be super speedy also this is where the
internet comes in since my internet
isn't faster than one gigabit anyways
this also allows me to save a port on
the 10 gigabit switch so i just need to
have internet in on that switch and the
one gigabit switch has internet in and
internet out essentially just to the 10
gigabit switch but could also go out to
other switches as well finally i just
slapped my older 100 megabit per second
switch in the rear i don't actually
think i'm going to be using or needing
this so i'm really just storing it back
there to be honest but this is also
power over ethernet or poe so i might
end up using it later for cameras or
raspberry pi's it's just some it's just
there if i need it but also i'm just
storing it back there so much of the
stuff on the server rack doesn't even
cover like half of the depth so there's
actually a lot of storage area back
there there's a lot of things i might
wind up putting in the back of the rack
one annoying aspect to having multiple
machines is multiple inputs and outputs
you can certainly remote shell or remote
desktop to control and operate them but
there are always downsides and nothing
beats a direct connection with a desktop
ui in my opinion
especially when i'm working with
multiple operating systems and things
that have some sort of ui requirement
and while i can work completely within
the shell i would just usually rather
work with a ui anyways so along with
consolidating power and networking i'm
also doing this for all the other
machine i owe to do this i'm going to be
using a kvm switch kvm stands for
keyboard video and mouse and the switch
part lets me switch between multiple
machines using that same keyboard and
mouse for all of them the way this works
is i plug my main mouse and keyboard
into the kvm switch the kvm switch that
i have has 16 vga out then i use these
vga cables that split out to vga and usb
and connect those to my machines most of
my machines don't have vga out so i'm
using displayport and hdmi converters
the interesting thing here to me is the
kvm switch is actually reporting the
mouse and keyboard information out over
vga before it splits out to usb for the
machine i didn't actually know that was
possible before mounting and wiring
everything i just wanted to make sure it
would work as i intended and hoped for
so here i've just connected a windows
and an ubuntu machine and can switch
between the two of them with the push of
a button some kvm switches also come
with remotes but i plan to use my kvm
switch close enough to just press the
buttons so since everything's working in
the kvm switch goes i didn't have a
monitor mount quite yet so i just sat
the monitor on top of the nas unit
it doesn't look great but it works
pretty well actually and it fits next in
goes the universal rails to support the
box machine this is my 2x rtx 8000
machine
though i've put one of the rtx 8000's in
the puget machine temporarily the box
workstations can come with mounting
hardware but at the time that i got the
box machine i didn't need it so i didn't
get it one nice thing about actual
sliding rails which you can get for the
box machines is they don't take up any
space beyond the size of the casing that
you're mounting but in my case the box
machine is going to have to sit on top
of universal rails this means that
there's the added thickness of the rail
itself and then the rails that i'm using
are also variable in size so in the
middle they actually double up in
thickness while small this ends up
adding up to being something like two
thirds of a centimeter or so in added
thickness which can honestly make or
break a mount fitment especially if
you're using this mounting method in
succession so in this case this added
thickness is indeed enough to block me
from actually getting the box in
initially so
first it's time to make some adjustments
to the casing immediately i removed the
top cover this was always going to have
to come off i think it's really only
here if the machine is being used in
workstation form but also because of
this waviness uh it does add a little
bit to the width of the machine when
it's in like rack mount orientation and
then i also just slid off the side panel
to the actual machine with the official
mounting hardware i am pretty confident
that this side panel could actually stay
but like i said we've got a few extra
millimeters with the rails that i'm
using so we need to free up any bits of
space that we can also i already know
there's some wiggle room when it comes
to the monitor mounting so i loosened
the nas screws a bit and lifted that
whole machine up just slightly but that
ever so slight bits that we can move
those things
that accounts for millimeters so i moved
that whole machine up slightly
re-tightened everything and then retried
the box again and in this setup the nas
will wind up kind of serving as the
box's side panel and the only time it
will come off is if i pull out the box
to do work on it or something like that
so this should still keep it closed and
dust away and all that and with that the
box machine finally fits so from here i
wire up the box to the kvm switch and i
boot that at the moment the box machine
is actually on gta data collection duty
for the self-driving car project so it's
currently running windows the next order
of business is to install a 1u drawer
with cable holes in the back i am at
least for now going to be using this to
house the keyboard and the mouse that
controls the kvm switch and all of the
machines and i can confirm it works for
my very official business while the
monitor can just sit on top of the nas
and be fully functional it would look
much cooler actually mounted on here so
here i have an adjustable depth monitor
mount so i disconnected the monitor
getting ready to mount it and there's
trouble in paradise the flat part of the
monitor stand comes off really easily
but the neck part seems stuck and i'm
pretty confident that i'm going to have
to like take the monitor apart just to
get this neck part off so i start
unscrewing things and prying away and
sure enough once i get inside i can see
that there's definitely no way this neck
would have come off without opening up
the actual casing of the monitor and
unscrewing it which is kind of weird for
a monitor with vesa mounts but so be it
because this monitor is special i bought
this monitor four years ago for one
simple reason it was the cheapest 1080p
monitor available on amazon little did i
know that four years later it would
actually be just about the most perfect
fit possible for my server rack
especially nowadays with monitors and
their casing being rounded or curved
very often it's actually really
challenging to find one that fits
between the 19-inch posts and is just a
nice simple flat square monitor you can
also look for actual rack mount monitors
and such but what you find is extremely
painful and extremely expensive also
just noting the photos that are used on
these product pages is kind of weird
like who's watching american football or
nature documentaries on their server
rack it's just kind of weird so besides
monitors there are also entire kvm
consoles that act as the kvm switch
monitor keyboard and mouse and they're
all contained within one unit the
problem is these are all proprietary in
like way too many ways so if like the
screen fails what are you going to do
what if the keyboard fails etc they're
all made by companies that i have no
trust or faith in they're extremely
expensive and always have really shaky
reviews and feedback the one benefit
that they have is they can take up as
little as one u of rackspace and
oftentimes that is of the utmost
importance my kvm switch alone takes up
one whole rack unit and then the monitor
just in size is a bit over six units
you could stuff in things in two of
those units and they would just be like
blocked by the monitor but no matter
what this whole setup that i'm doing is
going to take up a good chunk of unit
space and that's why there are solutions
that only take up one rack unit but this
is my rack and 42u is way more than i
need right now anyways i got 42u just
because somehow it was the cheapest
variant of the rack at the time and i
really enjoy having direct i o access
and i do quite literally want to be able
to monitor my machines in the rack so
for me this is just the perfect setup
next while i do plan to convert a few
more machines to be mounted in the rack
i don't quite yet have the cases for
them but i'd still like to utilize the
rack networking power and the
convenience of the kvm switch plus i'm
also just really enjoying how easy it is
to move everything around as one big
unit so i grab some scrap wood to cut
and make a floor for the rack just
temporarily so after cutting those
pieces i've got a nice simple floor to
rest machines on again i promise this is
this is temporary so now things are
definitely starting to come together but
there is one glaring issue here i don't
currently have anything i want to put
here at the moment i could put in that
other switch that i put in the back but
that switch is blue and it just would
look weird so for now in goes a blanking
panel i can figure out what to do with
that later finally i'm adding a 2u
drawer i'm going to be using this to
store rack specific things like cage
nuts and some spare parts for the cases
and the builds that are actually in the
rack the rack itself also came with
quite a few cage nuts and bolts but i'm
starting to run low so i wanted to get
some more and
this is what i got i actually ordered
the same ones they're the star tech cage
nuts and bolts but they really look like
they were salvaged from like a sunken
ship or something and the like the
packaging and everything was fine it
like the actual shipping packaging but
but this the packaging here like i don't
know where these came from but
pretty crazy
so i ended up buying these ac infinity
cage nuts and screws from the
recommendation of someone instead i just
had zero faith in like sending these
ones back and then reordering the same
ones like i'm pretty sure they're all
gonna come from like the same warehouse
and i just felt like there's too much
risk that the ones that i would get
would just be super rusted again and at
least these ac infinity ones have no
rust anyways the rack is getting pretty
far along now moving forward i would
like to add some ups slash battery
backup for sure for the nas maybe for
some of the other small things
along with converting a few more
machines that i have to rack mount and
then it's really just a function of kind
of cleaning up cabling maybe adding some
sort of global rack monitoring with
raspberry pi or something like that but
otherwise i'm quite happy with how
things have turned out so far so that's
all for now hopefully you guys have
enjoyed questions comments concerns
suggestions whatever feel free to leave
them below otherwise i will see you all
in another video
you